60 year-old John karanji lost five
members of his family his wife his
daughter and three grandchildren they
were among the 157 people killed in last
month's Ethiopian Airlines crash the
remaining members of the Carranza family
are yet to come to terms with the
situation here we are talking of our
estrogen bye bye we have not buried any
part of your loved ones it was a memory
surface and whatever your letter came up
with his mama diamond is a monument so
you keep smiling as he waits for the
remains of his relatives karanji is
keeping up to date with news regarding
the crash he even has a hard copy of
Boeing CEO Dennis Muhlenberg condolences
but it brings can't comfort you know I
need the clarification
where they never resolved the issue
because now they are ready to let
registration so why didn't they do that
in the first instance yes we except I
accept his apology but still there is a
lot of pain the Carranza family now
plans to sue Boeing
they put profit before life okay and the
worst thing is this is happening
it has attended not once but twice okay
so at least they need to to be held
accountable and to also be hit write
much as most receive their putting
profit before life where we need to go
after their profit two related cases
have already been filed against Boeing
several families of the Kenyan victims
are also planning to sue Ethiopian
Airlines and Boeing in coming days and
they're those who are seeking closure in
other ways each family of the victims of
the Ethiopian plane crash were given
soil to bury but the Quran has decided
not to they built this memorial and they
hope that eventually they will have
remains to bury